we've got some breaking news this
morning according to MSNBC a new
far-right Behavior has just dropped and
that behavior is
exercise
MSNBC writes quote the far rights
obsession with Fitness is going digital
now Libs had already warned us about
certain other behaviors that are markers
of far white far right
white supremacist
Neo-Nazi extremism behaviors such as
working hard
being on time and speaking English
when the libs announced those three
indicators of far-right behavior I have
got to admit I got a little bit worried
now however I feel much better I am in
no danger of radicalization or far-right
extremism because if working out is
right wing baby I am a regular Bernie
Sanders I'm Michael Knowles this the
Michael Knowles show
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode's
brought to you by genyourself skin care
get your Genius cell summer Essentials
package right now for over 70 percent
off seven zero percent off geniusell.com
slash Knowles Budweiser doing their best
to dig themselves out of that hole
partnering with Ken Griffey Jr
kind of a deep cut a little bit of a
throwback but okay we'll get to that in
just a second first though
boy I dodged a bullet didn't I
I was clearly on the path of far-right
extremism
you know I was showing up to work on
time
I was I made the okay symbol every now
and again someone says hey Michael this
is such and such sound good to you I say
okay that's fine oh that's a symbol of
far right white supremacist Neo-Nazi
extremism so I was nervous I was going
down that path but then I found out
that a key component of being right wing
is exercising and and treating your body
well and I obviously don't do that so I
think we're good I think I'm back to
being a Centrist now why are the libs
saying that working out is right wing
far right extremist
because the left is waging an all-out
war on normality that's why that's what
it's all about and that's why if you
think that this MSNBC headline is crazy
just wait the heat hits are going to
keep on coming
it's always about attacks on normality
because leftism is an attack unjustice
what is justice justice is run rendering
to each and to all what he deserves
religion is a habit of virtue that
inclines the will to render to God what
he deserves
Justice applies this principle to
everybody and leftism is all about
upending that normal Order of Things
giving to people what they do not
deserve taking from people what they do
deserve obviously ignoring religion
ignoring the moral order and making the
entire world about the self and the
satisfaction not of the higher will but
of Base appetites in this case literally
the bassist appetites in this case just
stuffing yourself and becoming a big
slob that's what it's after that's why
they attack Beauty that's why they
attack truth that's why they attack
goodness they are attacking Justice
broadly and I don't want to seem like
I'm being too harsh on the libs here or
I'm being hyperbolic or not giving them
their due that I'm being unjust or
something like that they're doing this
because they don't believe in objective
truth they don't believe in the moral
order that says that there's good and
there's evil and they believe the beauty
is in the eye of the beholder they don't
think that there are any objective
standards to beauty and so everything
just becomes about me me me me and when
everything is about me me me me then you
can't tell someone that they've got to
put the cupcake down and that they've
got to go maybe take a walk and have
some fresh air you you can't do that
because that would be to impose is some
external condition on somebody that they
do not accept
so you're not going to just see a
neglect of these objective standards
you're going to see an active undoing of
them this is why you saw in the
Netherlands the the recent Miss
Netherlands Crown Tiara going to a
we're not really allowed to talk about
on YouTube right now YouTube is really
against us talking about this important
social issue so if you want to hear my
commentary on those things you got to
listen on the RSS feed or watch it daily
wire Plus or head on over to Twitter at
the M Knowles Show Twitter account or
you can stick around because later on
for today's member block it will be
Tuesday so we'll get into issues and
we're not allowed to talk about on
YouTube
the Netherlands has just crowned some
[Music]
now speaking of the libs and speaking of
Ethics there's a big report out from
axios
which is the Joe Biden yells at his
staff headline Old Yeller
Biden's private Fury
in public President Biden likes to
whisper to make a point in private he's
prone to yelling apparently his
admonitions include quote g d it how the
F don't you know this don't F and Bs me
get the F out of here according to
current and former Biden AIDS who've
witnessed and been on the receiving end
of such outbursts
who go on it goes on to list all the
mean things that Biden does to his staff
and how much he's yelling at them okay
the way that this is being reported is
as though this is a leak from the White
House that's embarrassing to Joe Biden
and conservatives are taking that bait
and they're saying see this man he's
angry he's he's a loose cannon we need
to rein him in we need to get rid of
this guy he's just too vigorous and
and aggressive
I'm sorry to see conservatives taking
this bait this story is an obvious
strategic leak by the pro Biden forces
this is prop was probably leaked by the
Biden campaign
and the reason they leaked it is
at a shallow level it makes him look bad
because he's yelling at his staff but at
a deeper level it makes him look good
because it counters The Narrative that
we all see with our own eyes which is
that Joe Biden is a vegetable
the the bigger knock on Biden is not
that he gets angry and fired up the big
knock on Biden is he doesn't know what
day it is he has absolutely no energies
wandering around like a zombie and he
couldn't possibly muster the the Vigor
to to yell at his staff so they're
countering that with an ostensibly
negative story but really it's not that
negative we kind of like it when
executives
get fired up when they get a little bit
angry when they're tough on their staff
it means they're focused it means their
nose is in the details it means they
want to get something done this is this
is exactly the kind of image that
Biden's campaign wants to paint about
him and so what happens they give you
secret leaks from sources close to Joe
Biden just coincidentally right now well
his campaign is flailing and they give
it to an outlet that is obviously very
open to the left wing axios what they've
done here it's basically just the old
Ronald Reagan Mastermind sketch from
Saturday Night Live
all I can say is I didn't know
and well we're trying to find out what
happened because none of us know
the president well I hope I've answered
your questions as best I could given the
very little that I know
goodbye and God bless you thank you Mr
President thank you very much
okay get back in here
I'm only gonna go through this one so
it's essential that you pay attention
one Casey yes sir you'll spearhead our
new operation to fund the conference
back to work
in Afghanistan needs more money we've
got 65.2 million tucked away in Zurich
now if we hold it there for another 30
days at 7.28 interest that's roughly
four hundred thousand dollars 397
285 I know don't waste my time so this
is one of the greatest sketches in the
history of SNL highly recommend you go
back and watch the whole thing but this
is just what the Biden people are trying
to play him off as right now the knock
on Reagan was well he wasn't paying
attention to detailing he just wanted to
be an actor and say nice lines and so
the joke
all right is that actually secretly he's
he's The Mastermind running the Iran
Contra Scandal that's that's
doing here even this line that they're
attributing to Joe Biden uh how the F
don't you know this don't effing BS mean
the
premise there is that Biden knows
exactly what's going on so he can sniff
out the BS how do you not know this but
I presumably know this or I at least
know what you don't know
and
it's just the sketch and it's not true
I I am less inclined to believe that Joe
Biden yells at his staff today seeing
this leak than I was previously
they're trying to counteract much more
damaging and I think much truer
narrative homeboy is a vegetable now
when you want to look
at least smooth and vivacious as a
vegetable you're going to want to take
care of your looks you want to take care
of your skin you're going to want to
check out genucel right now go to
geniusell.com Knowles our friends over
at genucel sold out of their Dark Spot
Corrector and our listeners have been
begging begging on hands and knees for a
restock well I got great news just in
time for the summer back in stock
geniusell's famous Dark Spot Corrector
has not one but three Cutting Edge
ingredients and goes to work fast to
Target sun spots dark spots liver spots
and even old discoloration both on your
face and your hands you can now enjoy
your summer sun Beach and barbecues
without embarrassing spots geniusell's
most popular package also features their
summer Essentials such as the
best-selling Ultra retinol moisturizer
with a powerful retinol alternative for
safe use in the sun you will be amazed
at how quickly you will see results or
100 of your money back guaranteed I love
these guys especially the owner who's a
Coptic Christian who left Egypt for the
American dream head on over to
geniusell.com Knowles right now get get
your dark spot corrector in the genius
on most popular package geniusell.com
Knowles save over seventy seven zero
percent off janusel's most popular
package all orders will include a
mystery luxury gift while supplies last
janisl.com Knowles
the greatest interview show on YouTube
many people are talking about it yes or
no it's back with an all new episode
discussing the most talked about movie
in America sound of Freedom movie star
Jim Caviezel and American hero Tim
Ballard join for tough questions and
stiff drinks check out this teaser
coincidence that many Elites in
Hollywood and big Tech
critics of the sound of Freedom movie
does Michael think it's a coincidence
I'm just thinking about it for a second
don't give me the answer
it's cheating it's cheating
here's some more good news the yes or no
game the physical game is now back and
rather than giving Jeff Bezos more money
on Prime day you ought to give it to
Jeremy insteading at five bucks off when
you order yes or no go to dailywire.com
shop to get your game today that's
dailywear.com shop to get five dollars
off your order of the yes or no game
hurry before this deal ends
Joe Biden fading fast he's got no answer
on the age question which was softball
pitch to him by Fareed Zakaria on CNN
you've often said when people ask you
about your age just watch me
and I think a lot of people do watch you
and are impressed and they think you've
been a great president uh you've brought
the economy back you've restored
relations with the world but many of
these people do say and these are Ardent
supporters of yours
the next thing he should do is
step aside and let another generation of
Democrats take the Baton why are they
wrong
well let me not right or wrong it's a
look
use the phrase again I think we're on an
inflection point
I think the world is changing and I
think I
there is one thing that comes with age
if you're been honest about it your
whole life and that is some wisdom
I think we're on the cusp of being able
to make significant positive changes in
the world
this is going to be an unpopular take I
hate to say pains me that I have to say
it
I basically agree with Joe Biden here I
agree with him in principle
because he's articulating a principle
that conservatives have always known to
be true going all the way back to Old
Uncle Aristotle which is that
with age comes wisdom
I know there are there are some people
on the right who are a little bit more
libertarian minded who insists we need
young people to run the country we don't
want need those old fogies to run the
country we got to be super young that's
what's really important I don't buy that
at all Aristotle writes in his politics
that you want the old the older people
generally to rule and you want the
younger people generally to be the
active productive ones who are learning
the ropes and who are growing in wisdom
and then one day when they get older
they will rule
this is why I thought the attacks on
Dianne Feinstein were so ridiculous
Dianne Feinstein is a very aged Senator
that's true senatrix I guess she's a
lady Senator and she
what is she she's 90 years old or
something right now she's obviously got
some health problems that's true but
people are making fun of her for being
old I thought first of all I'm glad that
she's not quite so effective anymore
because it means that you don't have a
younger more vigorous more radical
Democrat in that seed from California
you've got a relatively more moderate
Democrat but two
do you know what Senate means
the word Senate refers to the Latin word
Senex
which is old
this means age
so you want that that's that's how the
system is built now the problem with Joe
Biden is that he's never possessed all
that much wisdom he's never possessed
that that much Prudence he's probably
wiser today than he was 50 years ago
but his view of the country is Wrong
is more corrupt than other politicians
and so that's the issue
but that doesn't mean that we all of a
sudden need a young guy
if you replace Joe Biden with Donald
Trump today 97 of the problems in the
country would immediately improve
maybe even more than that
maybe you could replace him with a young
guy like Ronda Santos Rhonda Santa seems
to be a very sharp guy he's got a great
head on his shoulders
but even to that point desantis's
campaign is not doing very well right
now in the Republican primary
I think the expectations for Rhonda
Santos were much higher and right now
Trump is leading by a lot which we'll
get to in just one second so
I don't I don't want to be too nice to
Joe Biden here but I want to call it
like I see you know I don't want to just
be some Republican party hack Joe Biden
actually just said something very smart
about Ukraine there's this major push to
admit Ukraine to Nato which I think is
absolutely insane Joe Biden is pushing
the brakes on that a little bit
I've spoken lent about this
and uh one of the things I indicated is
the United States would be ready to
provide while the process was going on
and it's going to take a while
while that process is going on to
provide security Allah the security we
provide for you for Israel providing the
Weaponry the needs the capacity to
defend themselves if there is an
agreement if there is a ceasefire if
there is a peace agreement and so I
think we can work it out and but I think
it's premature to say to call for a vote
you know in now because I there's other
qualifications that need to be met
including democratization and some of
those issues
wait wait wait
I thought that Ukraine was a pillar of
Western democracy I thought
that Vladimir zielinski was the modern
day Winston Churchill he's the great
defender of democracy
more American than the Americans frankly
that's it that's the big fight Freedom
versus tyranny Ukraine versus versus
Russia democracy versus autocracy now
you're telling me that Ukraine cannot be
admitted to Nato right now because they
need democratization
you saw that first part
where Joe Biden he says look you know
we're at War right now Ukraine is at War
we can't we're not going to admit them
obviously that's the reason if you
admitted Ukraine to Nato today it would
instantly trigger Article Five we'd be
in a world war with Russia be in a
nuclear war almost certainly then you
say wait it needs democratization so and
he's right about that by the way Ukraine
is an extremely corrupt country and the
BS that the libs have been telling us
about how Ukraine is a pillar of
democracy or whatever is obviously fake
news and Joe Biden just admitted that
he's made a wise observation
that has undermined his political
position this happens a lot to Joe Biden
actually
Joe Biden will make really wise
observations about crime let's say don't
forget the best accomplishment Joe Biden
ever read in his political career was
the 1994 crime bill which got tougher on
crime
but then that now undermines this
political position because Joe Biden as
a politician in 2023 is pro-crime and
he's anti-law enforcement
he does this a lot so the pro the
problem with Joe Biden is not that he
doesn't have any wisdom he's got more
wisdom than most people in the Democrat
Party the problem is that he's corrupt
in an empty suit and he'll just lick his
finger and put it in the air and figure
out which way the wind blows I think a
lot of people I don't know about 80
million but a lot of people voted for
Joe Biden there were a lot of people in
America in 2020 who did in fact
consciously vote for Joe Biden not after
death like so many Democrat voters but
while they were alive they voted for Joe
Biden and why I think they voted for him
because he was promising a return to
normality
and they saw that the left had been
ruthlessly attacking normality and
Donald Trump fairly or unfairly was
portrayed as
of opposing normality and these except
for kind of figure even if you love the
guy and so they voted for Joe Biden for
that purpose but the problem is because
Joe Biden's corrupt and because he's an
empty suit
he didn't deliver on that normality even
if those might have been his instincts
now speaking of violence overseas
speaking of attacks on Law and Order
Injustice London mayor Sadiq Khan
has finally spoken out about his City's
growing crime problem
and here's what he said he said there's
no place for crime in London but we
can't arrest ourselves out of the
problem from removing knives from our
streets to providing young londoners
with meaningful and engaging activities
I am committed to being tough on crime
and its complex causes but he's
obviously not committed to that because
he's saying you can't arrest yourself
out of the problem and I'm here to tell
you I don't have a PhD in criminology
okay
no I don't have a PhD in Psychology or
anything like that but I'll tell you
you can just arrest them if you arrest
the criminals
then they will stop stabbing and robbing
people on the street because they'll be
in prison
when they're in prison they can't they
might still stab each other a little bit
you got to watch that too but they won't
be doing that to people on the street if
you want if you want crime to go down
you need the arrests to go up and then
after you the arrests go up you've got
to prosecute them and put them in prison
if you have a crime problem then what
that means is you have an under
incarceration problem and it's not just
her in London it's true in America too
and to hear the libs whine about our
over incarceration problem is obviously
absurd as crime rates soar in America's
cities but it drives me even crazier
when I hear people on the right
it's a small group of squishy people on
the right but they'll they'll talk about
the over-incarceration problem because
they think it'll buy them brownie points
with the left or something or maybe they
bought into some bizarre magical
thinking whereby if you if you legalize
all sorts of disordered activities and
destructive activities
and if you stop arresting people and
enforcing the law somehow people are
going to be more inclined to follow the
law about the civil law and the natural
on the moral law and that's obviously
not the case you you can you can't
arrest yourself out of the problem you
can arrest the criminals and that will
solve your problem for you but if even
the mayor of London doesn't get that
if the president of the United States
can't get these basic things if we've
got an all-out assault by the entire
liberal establishment on all normality
and all common sense then you're gonna
have
nonsensical statements such as that now
speaking of the UK
our friend Nigel farage
guy I really like leader of brexit
he gave that great speech at the
European Parliament
or he's got the union Jackie says I came
here some years ago I said Britain was
going to leave the European Union
you all laughed at me well Who's
Laughing Now Nigel farage great cigar
guy great conservative leader so I'm not
that long ago at CPAC
Nigel is facing some real problems back
in his own country namely
they won't let him have a bank account
I've got a phone call a couple of months
ago to say we are closing your accounts
I asked why no reason was given I was
told unless it would come which would
explain everything the letter came
through and simply said we are closing
your accounts we want to finish it all
by a date which is around about now
I didn't quite know what to make of it I
complained that I emailed the chairman a
Lackey phone me uh to say that it was a
commercial decision
which I have to say I don't believe a
single moment so I thought well there we
are I'll have to go and find a different
bank I've been to six no seven Banks
actually
um asked them all could I have a
personal and a business account and the
answer has been no in every single case
without a bank account you effectively
become a non-person you don't actually
exist it's like the worst regimes of the
mid 20th century be they in Russia or
Germany you literally become a
non-person and you don't anymore you did
in the past but you don't anymore
actually had a right to be entitled to a
bank account
you did in the past but you don't now
meaning it's not just the leftists who
grow the big government who are coming
for you and who are threatening your way
of life sometimes it's even the
deregulators who are ruining your way of
life because in this case Nigel is not
being oppressed by his government he's
being oppressed by the free market he's
being oppressed by corporations he's
being impressed by Banks who are saying
because you are politically
controversial by the way how's he
controversial he's just a normal guy who
said that Britain should be Britain and
not have to tailor their entire Society
over to the whims of people in Germany
and France
for saying that
for being in any way kind of
conservative Nigel doesn't get to have a
bank account and if you think it's just
him you think it's just going on in the
UK or it's just going on to a big
political leader like Nigel farage you
are mistaken there is a major effort
underway being pushed by big voices on
the stage of the world economic foursome
to bring this kind of control and
Punishment to you which we'll get to in
a second first up how's your health care
do you want to check out maybe Samaritan
Ministries right now go to
samaritanministries.org Knowles how are
you paying for your health care how's it
working out for you if it's working out
perfectly great okay cool if not listen
closely because I have a solution for
you a Biblical solution called Samaritan
Ministries Samaritan Ministries is a
community of Christians paying one
another's medical bills it's affordable
health care sharing and because it's not
Insurance there are no restrictive
networks here's how it works when a
medical need arises you choose the
health care provider that is right for
you and have a say in the treatment you
receive send your medical bills to
Samaritan Ministries they will notify
fellow members to pray for you and send
money directly to you to help you pay
those bills it could be more affordable
than what you are paying ma'am and if
it's the right fit you can join anytime
even today check it out at
samaritanministries.org Knowles Canada
w-les that is Samaritan Ministries dot
org slash Knowles
okay folks time to put that Bud Light
boycott money to good use lucky for you
we've come up with the cure to bite
inflation and that is a mega sale right
now you can get up to forty four zero
percent off select items from Jeremy's
razors products such as the hair and
body bundle I use their shampoo just
today I use it almost every day the
beard kit our smooth six starter set and
more don't miss out because this sale
will not last longer Jeremy's racers.com
get that 40 off Jeremy's razors.com
today my favorite comment yesterday is
from J
kemp6791 not to be confused with jcam
6790 or any of the previous 6790 Jay
camps who says if protecting children
from sex trafficking endangers your
political agenda that says a whole lot
more about you than it does about some
movie that you don't like yes in a movie
that they don't like not because the
acting is bad the acting is superb not
because the production is bad the
production is extraordinarily high
quality it's because they don't like
story
which is a true story but it's a story
that they are implicated in in defending
and directing attention away from
the libs are not only trying to take
away Nigel farage's bank account and
ability to engage in the economy they're
coming after yours
eswar Prasad is a senior professor of
international trade policy at Cornell
ivy league university senior fellow at
the Brookings institution major
center-left liberal Think Tank formerly
worked as the chief of the international
monetary funds financial studies
division here he is on stage at the
world economic Forum panel in China
discussing
how they're going to control your money
the one final note I will make is that
if you think about the benefits of
digital money there are huge potential
gains it's not just about digital forms
of physical currency you can have
programmability you know units of
Central Bank currency with expiry dates
you could have as I argue in my book a
potentially better and some people might
see it on a darker world where the
government decides that units of central
bank money can be used to purchase some
things but not other things that it
deems less desirable like say a munition
or drugs or pornography or something of
this sort and that is very powerful in
terms of the use of a cbdc
so this is coming this is coming here
soon
and
if you're like me if you're not just an
arch hardcore libertarian if you're a
little more conservative
then you'll listen to this and you'll
say well you know what in principle
I don't think that money should be
permitted to be used for certain
purchases
and in fact our law today reflects that
you're you're not allowed to go purchase
drugs at least in normal cities you're
not allowed
at least According to some laws that are
no longer really enforced you're not
allowed to go purchase pornography in
certain places that's always been the
case in American history and that's good
the mechanism for control was a little
bit weaker
and a little bit less subject to capris
but then you heard that that third thing
they mentioned there porn yeah I don't
think you should be able to buy porn
drugs yeah I don't think you should be
able to buy illicit drugs obviously
ammunition
well hold on a sec we have a second
amendment in this country we have more
guns in this country than people we have
a natural right to self-defense
you're telling me now like you're you're
broadcasting this before you even get
the digital currency your your
telegraphing that you will
use this new technology to stop us not
from engaging in Vice which in principle
I have no problem with
but to stop us from engaging in virtue
to stop us from exercising our natural
rights which derive from the natural law
coming here soon folks unless we stop it
as a matter of prudence even if you're
not opposed to a digital currency as a
matter of technology or
political morality
prudentially
practically speaking this will be used
against conservatives they're going to
do exactly what they're doing to Nigel
to us so who's going to lead the fight
back
if you look at the numbers today it's
Trump it's Trump trump is leading in all
the polls by a lot including in Florida
now this is really tough number for Ron
DeSantis is from Florida Atlantic
University FAU poll
Trump is up 20 points on DeSantis in
Florida
in Florida Trump said 50 percent
DeSantis 30 the vague four percent Tim
Scott three percent Chris Christie the
chrysosan's not looking as great as it
once did two percent
it's down there with Asa Hutchinson
Pence two percent Haley one percent
even when you just put DeSantis and
Trump against one another head to head
so you say okay well you don't want the
field to to water down to Santa's
support what's it look like when they're
up against each other Head to Head
Trump's numbers go up actually 54 to 37
so it's his numbers go up
objectively you're 54 versus 50. but
then he still maintains a 17-point lead
over DeSantis Ron DeSantis needs a
radical reset of his campaign
and so there's no other way to put it
DeSantis just announced that he wasn't
going to speak at TP USA
which
in a short-term way is probably smart
because tpusa has a strong relationship
with Donald Trump I bet there are a lot
of people at tpusa who would be totally
open to a DeSantis nomination maybe most
of them I don't know I mean I think
these are this is the largest
a gathering of young conservatives in
the country Charlie Kirk puts on these
huge Gatherings of young conservative
students so they might be open to Ron
DeSantis but but the descendants
campaign might be thinking okay well if
I go there and then I get booed on stage
that's going to look really bad for me
and I guess it would look bad but also
if you can't win over those guys if you
can't win over Young Americans
which
is the group that should be most likely
to embrace DeSantis over Trump and if
you can't win over tpusa which is more
conservative than the establishment GOP
groups and if you can win over Trump
voters
then you can't be the nominee desantis's
campaign requires him to win over a
large number of trump voters DeSantis is
not running in the Chris Christie Lane
he's not running in the Tim Scotland
Nikki Haley Lane the Mike Pence line
he's running in the Trump Lane he's
running in the conservative little bit
more populist a little bit more shaken
things up kind of Lane which means you
got to take Trump's voters and if you
can't take Trump's voters then you
should drop out of the race but it's too
late for DeSantis to drop out of the
race
Trump is as vindictive as it gets when
it comes to politics DeSantis has been
in this too long the die is cast
so he's got to run this thing to win it
right now they are not running it to win
it right now they are running a very
confused strategy that is playing not to
lose and if you play not to lose long
enough maybe you'll be the second
loser or the number one loser meaning
the number two guy in the race but that
in a buck 50 will get you a cup of
coffee that is that is a a very foolish
campaign strategy and things are not
improving for De Santa so they've got to
make some drastic changes soon if they
want to keep up there's also a very rare
legislative misstep
for DeSantis I'm giving some out of the
box out of left field unpopular opinions
today so I'm gonna keep them coming
localities should be allowed to ban pit
bulls pit bulls commit all the dog
attacks pretty much and they're it's the
breed it's not the individual dogs it's
the breed dogs are not capable of reason
the breed is extremely dangerous it's
not the dog's fault but it's just the
way they're built and the mall little
toddlers and localities are entirely
within their rights to say that they
don't want to have pit bulls there
so DeSantis and the Florida legislators
the Republicans just passed a law
prohibiting localities from Banning pit
bulls localities in Florida have been
Banning pit bulls for a very long time
and then for no reason whatsoever for no
political benefit at all
Rhonda Santos was in the fight of his
life for president and the Florida GOP
go in and they say no you need to let
pit bulls come into your community and
eat your toddlers what the hell is going
in pain this guy started out so strong
he's been an excellent Governor he's
extremely intelligent he's very capable
and he's just getting bad advice right
now I don't know
don't know what they're doing goodness
gracious got to pray for our country
don't we well you want to pray you might
want to check out hello right now go to
hallow.com it is clear that the left is
giving up their morals into any Common
Sense there's no better time to build a
daily habit of prayer and meditation
building a habit of prayer can help you
cultivate an attitude of gratitude
focusing on what you are thankful for
can increase positive emotions and
improve overall well-being hallow is the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
United States it's helped lots of people
maintain a daily prayer routine it can
help you to download the app for free at
hello.com Knowles you can set prayer
reminders and track your progress along
the way not sure where to start check
out father Mike schmitz's Bible in a
year one of the only podcasts I listen
to magnificent podcast available on the
Hallow app for brief daily readings and
Reflections or pray alongside Mark
Wahlberg Jim Caviezel and even some
world-class athletes with Halo you can
customize a personal prayer plan that
works for you listen wherever you are
with downloadable offline sessions using
how low to connect with others who share
your beliefs and values can provide a
sense of belonging support Foster a
sense of community
ultimately we learn how to become better
individuals in spite of today's broken
world and strive to become more like
Christ in our daily lives
download hello.com Knowles get an
exclusive three months free three months
absolutely freehello.com Knowles
also speaking of bad advice before we
get into uh this Tuesday member block
Budweisers keeps just to taking bad
advice Budweiser is trying to dig itself
out of this huge brand collapse the
brand collapse brought on by Bud Light
sponsoring
Bush totally embracing the rainbow flag
so they're trying to dig themselves out
and they try to dig themselves out by by
doubling down by portraying their
customers as fratty stupid rube idiot
Hicks by making a commercial with horses
but now they're doing a commercial with
Ken Griffey Jr
Ken Griffey Jr is a great baseball
player
especially when I was a kid he was he
was one of the biggest players in the
MLB
I Love Ken Griffey Jr that's great
it's not enough guys this is this is not
good for Budweiser this is bad for Ken
Griffey Jr this is this doesn't make me
more likely to buy a bud I am zero
percent more likely to buy a Budweiser
ever again after this ad I'm just less
likely to have affection for Ken Griffey
Jr okay this isn't working there's one
way for Budweiser to fix this apologize
say you opposed
say you don't want
you oppose the the crazy drag shows that
mock women and
performed
and you oppose all of that and you
support
normality just say hey we're Budweiser
we are the most normal beer in America
we had a little bit of a freak out over
there we're normal again we like normal
things drink us and be normal
and people might go back to Budweiser or
it might be too late okay it's Tuesday
where you know we're not allowed to talk
about this stuff on big Tech
so other than on Twitter Twitter lets us
talk about this so that means I'm not
going to censor what I'm saying I'm not
going to censor this show at all but
that means that you're gonna have to if
you want the whole show you got to go to
daily wear plus you got to go to Twitter
M Knowles show you got to go to the RSS
feed Apple podcast Spotify and you got
to go to the member block today is
Tuesday baby the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
the human member and use code Knowles
Canada wlas at checkout for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]